[Music]
hello everyone
thank you for joining us my name is
julianne i'm
the assistant director of involvement
at the mba admissions office at the
stanford graduate school of business
today's session is going to focus on
brazil
but we know that there are many of you
joining from all over the world
we have five fantastic alumni from
brazil
who will be the main focus of today's
event
so you'll get to hear from them again
this is really focused
on the alumni experience
hearing their stories and not admission
so we have a ton of other events
available some that do focus
specifically on admissions and so i do
encourage you to check those out as well
because today is really going to be
focused on the experience
so now i would like to shift gears a bit
and i'm going to turn it over to our
panelists
so for our panelists i'd like you each
to
introduce yourselves and maybe we can
just move in the order of the chart
starting with you mauricio
if you could share um your name
where in brazil you're from and then um
any sort of you know industry i know we
kind of captured broad
buckets here on our slide but any sort
of background information
uh you'd like to share and then
your favorite memory or favorite
experience from the gsb
perfect um so my name is mauricio
i was born in brasilia but i've been in
rio
since i was about 13 years old i
consider rio my hometown
and i'm the perfect example of a career
shifter because
i graduated communication social with an
emphasis in publicity propaganda which
is
advertising basically in marketing and
um
i went to work in a in a tv network
and kind of like the brazilian espn
and after a few years i realized i
wasn't satisfied so that's when i
decided
to apply for an mba and once i got there
it was it became very clear that i
wanted to work with startups and
technology i think a lot of people that
go to stanford
kind of find their passion for
technology
and i was after i graduated and i was
able to get into this industry
my first job after after stanford was
as country manager for via google a
ticketing company
ticketing marketplace and after three
years doing that
i finally gained the confidence and the
experience i needed to
start my own company so in 2017
i started volante which is a
e-commerce for used cars basically in
brazil and
and that's what i've been doing ever
since so stanford the goal of getting my
mba was to
shift my career and stanford and that
and much more
so i'm very satisfied with my career now
and the question was my favorite
experience overall or academic or
whatever
overall let's go with overall okay so
the trips the the trips especially the
student-led trips
i i went on three israel china and i led
the brazilian one
and i'll give you one example in israel
we sat at a table with you know
probably 25 students and and netanyahu
right so
that's not something that happens every
day that you can get to ask questions
and talk
there's only a few other people in the
room and you're having questions just
like we're speaking here so
the trips are amazing and this specific
trip was incredible
okay my turn so my name is erica um i'm
an nba 14.
um so i can't i guess i can say i also
shifted careers but it wasn't that fast
that's not easy it was
um so i worked in italy for about eight
years before i went to the just b
i was sponsored so i got my mba i came
back to tow and i worked there for
a bunch of years so i left ital a year
ago
a year and a half ago after working for
14 years there
i was working with technology and
digital i always worked with innovation
and that kind of stuff and then when i
came back i um
i started by building itau's connection
with startups so i built kubu
i led kobo for a while i led their
digital transformation
and then i started their um department
in
financial products in sorry in payments
in digital payments
and then about a year and a half ago i
decided it was time to
change something i didn't know exactly
what but i
um i also got pregnant and i decided it
was time to change
uh careers and i wanted to go to a more
digital company
and i had always talked with the people
in quintander because they're also
stanford um alums so i always talk to
gabriel and andrea about this and and
it's been it had been a while since i
started thinking about it and
i thought i wanted to change completely
and go to hr because i thought khr was
something that needed a transformation
not a lot of people knew how to do
um so i told gabrielle hey you know
thank you but i i want to be in hr and
he offered me the position to be the
head of people
in kentucky so here i am for the last
year actually it was here
a year yesterday um so it was a very a
pretty
big shift by someone who's graduating in
mathematics
um so i guess i chose to go to the gsb
because i wanted to keep working with
technology and because i didn't have all
that background in in management or
anything because i was
i was i graduated in math was it was a
very different background
um so i think stanford gave me all that
that
baggage and everything i needed the
expertise i needed to um do everything i
did ever since i came back but also
learn about the technology and startups
that's modi's so awesome
i think it was hard to say one only
memory
um i think i have too many um i can say
i met my husband if it makes sense but
i'm not gonna say that because everyone
says this is the only you know like
people go there to get married which i
did but that's okay
um so i think for me it was really the
people that was there like
and and i agree with my use so the trips
are great and academic
it was great too but i think the most
the best part is actually being on
campus and
meeting everyone and you know and then
leaving your house and going to the
talks and
seeing everyone there it didn't matter
what time it was or what
what you were doing you always met
people and you could talk about anything
you wanted there were people doing
all kinds of things different countries
everywhere and for me just
being close to everyone and how much
everyone was open
uh was the best thing
all right so it's my turn now uh hello
everyone i'm elena
i'm an mba 2015.
i currently work with innovation in the
energy sector
i just kind of switch sectors
um after well i i was in consulting
before going to just b
and i knew that i wanted to do a career
shift
so i and went to the just be my husband
was also
a student there so that was a fun
experience
we were already married before and when
i came back
to to brazil i went to the lemon
foundation
i was there for six years
uh um and i just switched
there i started the internal vc that
that the foundation has thinking about
how to invest in technology and net tech
and how to close the gap between those
who have access
to educational technology and those who
haven't
after that uh we actually bought
a startup and i joined the startup as
head of people finance operations
everything that wasn't product
i was the one doing it and so
after doing that for two years i decided
that i wanted to go to product
and i switched moves inside a startup a
little bit
i was head of product for
about a year and i was invited
uh in the beginning of the year to join
votering energia
that works with the energy sector uh
within a
a real challenge to understand that
energy is not a commodity anymore
and that what is happening is that the
the market is getting
is getting deregulated and people have
to
start we have to start paying attention
to our clients
so i thought that that was a nice
challenge
and i'm i've been there for about three
months
now and my favorite jxb jsp experience
i think i'll have to agree with mauricio
was like both
leading the gst to brazil in 2014
and going to the social trip innovation
in india
in which we try to understand and really
live the lives of people who are in the
poverty line
that was a real game changer experience
for me
and so i think that that that's
something i remind myself
a lot
great so hey everyone my name is daniel
i'm an mba from the class of 2019 so
graduated last year um my background is
somewhat traditional within business so
i did engineering at scala polytechnica
then did two years of investment banking
and two years of private equity at
carlisle
before going uh get my mba at stanford
and i think
i didn't shift careers or shift sectors
as part of my mba but i think a lot of
the motivation
that i had for for going pursue my mba
was
i realized during my time at carlisle
that
you know what what got me there wouldn't
get me to
the next level so until then a lot of my
work was focused on
financial modeling preparing
presentations doing analysis
and i realized that you know to continue
to advance in the career more and more
i'd have to rely on soft skills so being
able to convince
an entrepreneur a company owner to you
know have a conversation with us and
consider us
as potential investors or influencing a
company manager
to think about strategy in in a way that
we thought uh made more sense or
you know recruiting and hiring and
managing people
in the team and make sure that they were
motivated so i really wanted to
accelerate
my path in learning and developing soft
skills
which i thought an mba would help me do
it then and
stanford has a wonderful curriculum
uh in many ways but i think with a very
good emphasis in soft skills and i
i learned a lot uh during my time at the
nba
on this set of skills i'm happy to talk
more about that
during the q a portion and since i
graduated i
came back to the team at carlisle here
in sao paulo that focuses in
investments in in south america i think
in terms of
favorite memories uh so many and i echo
many of the the ones that were shared by
the other panelists but um i'll talk
about the trips as well and in
particular the
study trip that i collect to brazil
and i think there's there's just this
moment when by the end of the trip
you're having conversations with the 25
students the 25 nbas that came to visit
your country and they're telling you
about how you know they had this image
of what brazil was like
before coming in because of the trip now
they have such a more
nuanced view of brazil's challenges but
the opportunities
how there are exceptional business
people doing amazing things here and
just getting the sort of feedback from
these these people will be amazing
leaders and who didn't know
brazil very well before the trip i think
was just such a wonderful
moment so this is a very strong memory
that i have of my time at the gsp
hi everyone i'm thais uh i'm from the
class of 2019
i'm from salvador bahia brazil and um
before the gsb i was working at a real
estate development company
and when i graduated i decided to stay
in the
united states for a little bit longer so
i worked for
one year in a proptech company in san
francisco
and i recently moved back to brazil
so i'm working at a venture capital
company
uh here in brazil called maya capital
that invests in early stage company
in in latin and uh
i think i echo all the great experiences
and moments
that uh my fellow panelists
shared here so the relationships that we
built with amazing people
and also the trips and all the the
moments the special moments that we had
but also i wanted to share about one
favorite academic experience
that for me was the startup garage class
it was a very
special uh experience for me because it
was very hands-on and for me that was
like
pivoting to wanting to pivot to a new a
new career in tech
it was really good to have frequent
interaction with
mentors and also an amazing team of
classmates
and uh the class showed me the the
importance and
of some frameworks and paths to start a
company so it was
really interesting for me um very
special moment also with the gsb
thank you everybody um so i'm going to
move into there's already some great
questions coming into the q
a so we're going to move that way just a
reminder a reminder
to all of our participants um scroll
through the q a see if there's any
questions in there that you also have
and use a thumbs up to
upload it so that way i know that those
are the questions top of mind for folks
um so this question is actually
coming from camilla and she would like
to know if anybody took
classes outside of the gsp like at other
schools at stanford
and how was that experience and how easy
was it to have a multi-disciplinary
experience
maybe one or two panelists can answer
this
i have i have an interesting example um
i took public speaking with the
engineering undergrads
and it's it was interesting because
engineers
as you know don't really have the
profile of the public speak
um and so it was very interesting
because
us as mbas were trained and our previous
careers may kind of allow us to become
good at public speaking
but what a bunch of developers at
stanford who are very good at developing
code
aren't necessarily well trained to to
speak in public
and the experience of getting to know
these people and
helping them in some ways as they helped
me and and seeing what undergrad at
stanford is like
um that was fascinating it i evolved as
a public speaker
but i got to meet a lot of interesting
people
and i think i became better at that
specific skill
because the people who are taking the
class with me are so different
the background is so different and
they're good at different things
it was very complimentary and i'm very
glad i took that class
i i can go i i took a bunch of classes
at the d school because i worked with
the innovations i'm thinking in italy
before i went
so i went i really wanted to learn it
better and
and come back um to do that better so i
did a bunch of classes and it was really
interesting because
it was a mix of people from different
schools not only the jsp
not only engineering but people from a
bunch of places
and i took one that was very nice that
was um we had a group of four people
two of the uh of their um the design
school fellows which are
a master's program that they do with
very few people and until they just be
and we were connected with a company and
we had to solve a real problem
ours was dropbox and we spent a quarter
going to dropbox with the guy who was
the head of design and innovation
of dropbox who was like the fourth
employee of facebook before that
and trying to understand a problem and
solving a problem with them which was an
amazing opportunity i don't think i
could ever have that opportunity
anywhere else
could it just one thing um
[Music]
i took a few classes go across the
street so in other schools
outside of the business school and i've
had great experiences i just wanted to
say that from a systems perspective
the this works very well at stanford so
it's very easy for you to take classes
in other schools regardless of
which ones are your interests if it's
computer science or
you know engineering or whatever it is
um it's very easy to enroll in classes
in other schools
and most of the classes count towards
the credits for your degree
so it's a very friendly system that
encourages you to take classes and
whatever fields of
interest you might have
okay so narelle would like to know um
looking a little bit more about finances
how are you able to finance did anybody
get any loans from the united states or
have any financial aid and what was that
process like
i can go with that um i before i
i entered the gsp i thought i couldn't
do it and pursue an mba because of the
lack of financial resources and i wasn't
in sponsored by any company
so uh it was the the whole admissions
office and and the team helped me a lot
to understand that
once you get accepted they
want us to be there so they will help us
with getting loans uh
being international it's it's okay that
there are some
providers that will help uh give us
loans and it was
super easy uh and i'm glad i pursued
this because
i thought it was not possible going that
uh pursuing the mba with all the
financial resources before but the
admissions office and the financial
office helped us a lot and
it was total totally possible
thank you um helena could you talk about
if this is in in your situation but
could you talk about why you chose to
apply to the gsb
at all versus other top schools
sure uh well i i went to
visit a lot of schools before i applied
and one thing that really well i
i actually got the the atmosphere and
the values and met the people
that were studying there and it's funny
enough my
husband went with me and he wasn't going
to apply for an mba
it was like no mba it's not for
interpreters i think
i don't need it and when we got to the
gsp he looked at me and he's like i'm
gonna be so pissed if i'm here for two
years and i didn't even try
to to apply and so he ended up applying
as well and we both got
in but the main thing was the values i
think i really connected
with the values there and with the
people
uh who are there they were very friendly
and
they they invited me to see classes i
actually met
erica uh there during that time
and we are very good friends uh and then
i think it was amazing because i already
had friends during my visit
so i think that that's the kind of
people you're going to meet
and the kind of people who will stay
with you
in your life for a very long time
um maybe you could take this one and
um mauricio you may also be able to jump
in on this too but could you talk a
little bit about
um what the best communities classes
professors or experiences are for
pursuing entrepreneurship or interested
in pursuing entrepreneurship
yeah sure so the one that i mentioned
the startup garage was
really important for me because as i
said i was connected to mentors and also
to
classmates that were interested in this
industry in this ecosystem
another one another class that was
really important was uh formation of new
ventures which is a class that
shows different paths to start a company
so
starting from the idea starting from the
team starting from the problem
so it was opened my mind a lot of
different ways to start
companies and thinking about different
uh
communities there are uh there are
different clubs in the
in the school i was closer to the alaska
club which is latin america
uh student association so i was one of
the co-presidents of this club
and we did a lot of entrepreneurship
things but for
the region so it was really cool to be
involved with
this with this club i i really want to
highlight
the startup garage class i took it as
well i took both semester i took both
quarters you you start uh
trying to build the the product and the
next quarter you actually actually
have to have revenue on it and i i still
i still have the notes from that class
and every time and it doesn't
only apply to a product it applies to
a way of thinking that you can uh
use in any kind of in the industry
and i think it's really it's not a class
it's it's an experience so i i really
agree with tai is there um
julianne i think you can help me because
it's been a while i graduated 2013 it's
been
more than i'd like but um the one where
eric schmidt
teaches is it entrepreneurship and
venture capital
okay so that that was
i'll never forget that class because not
only because of eric schmidt and then we
got to have lunch with eric schmidt it
was only five people plus him for those
of you who don't know eric schmidt
is the former president of google um and
there was one day specifically where
this young
undergrad came to speak to us and the
professor just said yeah he's launching
an app
i don't know much about it but people
are talking about this kid so he's
coming to speak
he was the founder of snapchat i forget
his name now because again it's been a
while
but um he was just talking about the app
that he this was 2012 i believe
maybe 2013. um the app that he was
building that was getting a lot of
traction
at the university blah blah and i
remember thinking
he thinks a lot like he seems a little
bit cocky
but then i discovered that there was
merit behind it right
it became a snap that became so
that kind of stuff i believe does not
happen in a lot of the mbas
but it happens at stanford and i agree
about formation of new ventures that
that was remarkable as well
thank you just to add one more that i
just remembered it's managing growing
enterprises
it's actually about the human
relationships
when your startup starts growing and
a lot of different cases that that will
for sure happen
and conflicts that will happen so
basically the class
is a role play uh between all those
conflicts and it's
really hard to get out of some of them
and to solve some of them so
i i still use a lot i always think what
grossbeck
would do in that situation he's one of
the
was one of the first professors of mg
daniel i'm going to turn to you and kind
of maybe building off of
of that train of thought denise would
like to know if you could expand a bit
about
what you share with your soft skill
development um
and have you encountered situations
after graduation when you've been able
to apply
what you learned with those soft skills
yeah absolutely so just to give
a few examples of classes that i took i
also took the public speaking classes
mauricio took at the engineering school
which is
excellent gives you a lot of space to
practice
i took a negotiations class at the law
school
and lawyers are excellent at negotiating
so
lots of role plays and lots of
simulation and that was very good
but i think for me the most impactful
class was
interpersonal dynamics um best known as
tachichivi
which is probably the gsb's most famous
class this is an elective that i think
has existed for
50 60 years it's a very traditional
class of the gsb
it's an elective that i think over 90 of
the students of the gsb
take and basically the idea there is is
for you to
um become very very close with a group
of
10 or 12 students and really develop a
culture of feedback there so
you're interacting with these people um
and then you're giving feedback on how
your
interactions are affecting each other it
sounds a little weird and it's kind of
weird to explain it really works when
you're in the classroom
and i think what's amazing about this
class is you gain a level of
transparency about
how other people are actually feeling
and reacting to your behavior
that i think helps you build a lot of
empathy for people
i think now in my job and even in my
daily life
whenever i have an interaction with
someone that doesn't go
the way i expected i think i have a lot
more tools to
take a step back and try and understand
and empathize
and see where they're coming from and
why it might be that they are
behaving that way so i think it gives
you a lot of um
sensitivity for uh for interacting with
others
uh in a way that would be very hard to
develop if you weren't in this academic
safe space you know i want to add
something to that too um when i was
applying
a former boss in itau who was an
executive director
told me remember you're leaving to
become a better leader
not a better financial analyst and that
really resonated with me and i ended up
really picking the classes on that
i did i don't i don't even know if they
still have it but i did the arbocal
fellowship
program um which was a program uh that
we learned to be
better mentors and coach people um we
had to take the touch affiliate class
before everyone else was allowed to in
the first year
and it took us it was a lot of work for
the first two quarters of the second
year
because we had to minister a class for
the first quarter and then to mentor
and coach three um people two to three
students of the next class
but it was something that really really
helped me grow and develop
and i think it changed the way i did
everything from there i already
i was already a manager for i don't know
around 10 or 12 people before i left
but when i came back and i grew very
fast in the bank and i
i ended up having like 200 people and i
think those
things also made me want to change to hr
right those things kind of
showed me all different things and and
ended up in the end
changing my career
eric i'm actually going to go back to
you for this next question
um and then start with you and then
anyone else who wants to join in please
do
um we'd like to let out camilla like a
little bit more about the gsb
network so the question is do you feel
your gsb network is as strong outside of
the united states
as it is inside of the u.s and can
anyone provide an example
of how the gsb network may have helped
you get ahead in your career or your
life
i dare to say it's stronger for us here
than it is in the u.s
and i can give you tons of examples um
i do not do anything before talking to
norissa here or elena here and
i can give you a bunch of like i don't
know maybe 12 to 15 examples
i work with four other gsb actually five
reflectors five other gs beers in the
company i work with
um when i came back to italy when i
decided to
to to start kubo we i had no idea what i
was doing no one had ever done that
in anywhere else in the world and i
approach it as a
like everyone is saying here this
laboratory right i'm starting a new
business so i need to start it and
understand it
and i don't think if i if i i actually
think that if i didn't
if i hadn't gone to the to the just be
or met the people i met i don't think i
would have been able to do kubo as it
was
because all those people i'm telling you
maldives to elena edward dubai
or pedro elena's husband i can give you
i don't know 20 examples of people who
helped me understand what i needed to do
and to get where i needed to get and i i
needed to talk to investors
entrepreneurs and a bunch of different
people
academics and companies and everyone
helped me so much
and when i left itau like i talked to
all these people
and we have entrepreneurs we have people
in big companies we have people who
founded companies
um and i talked to everyone to
understand what i wanted to do because i
literally had no idea where to go to
um and i know i've talked to other
people here too i talked to thais before
she came as well
so we we help each other so much that i
can really
i can't even begin to explain how much
we it is
even even i mean we're not a lot of
people but we're very close
and i think we help each other a lot and
in the u.s it's it's different but it's
amazing right if
you need something when i wasn't in town
that happened a lot like i need to
understand
this specific thing about payments i
know this company is good just
in the alumni book and find someone just
email in half an hour then it was back
you know and this is amazing um so i
don't know i have
i can give you a hundred of examples i
can give a very
tangible example sorry i can give you a
very tangible example that happened a
month ago
so the company i work with uh
did uh 150 million donation
for to to um work with the
the kovid crisis and i'm in the
committee that says
where we are going to invest that money
and uh what happened here in brazil was
that there was a lack of supplies
for hospitals for example well in a lot
of countries that happened but we
basically
uh had to fund research that was going
in universities to to find alternate
alternatives
for those kinds of supplies and one um
what's up that i sent into our group
i got more than 50 initiatives
in universities around brazil and we
ended up investing in four of them
and we also supplied other companies
with
other examples just because the network
knew what was happening
in the country and what kinds of
research was happening and that was in
like 15 minutes
when i came back with with the answers
to the committee
they couldn't believe it like how that
happened
so i think it's not only it's a will
that people have to they want to help
you and they want to make make sure
that they got your back and vice versa
oh if someone asked me you're only
allowed to answer
one thing that's good about stanford i
think it'll be the community
and the alumni i'm gonna give like four
quick examples
my first job after the nba uh the viago
company i mentioned was the stanford
founder he wanted someone from stanford
to run latin america
he emailed another gaddafi which is a
friend of ours
and fernando was at another startup so
he said mauricio's a good fit i got the
job and then i decided to start polanchi
three years later
um three classmates of mine at stanford
had started startups in the used car
space in the us i called all three of
them he gave me
insights and ideas and innovations about
the car industry and if i should go into
that space or not
and then i wanted to raise money uh i've
got a bunch of
angels in the company you know close to
20 i would say 80
of those people are just beers um i'm an
angel investment i've got over 10
companies in the portfolio 80 are gsp
companies
um i wanted to raise vc money for
volunteer guess who's on my board
carlos uh just be alarmed
and they're not from kazakh who's also
just be alone
so and then i and then people from
stanford we tried to hire etc
so i talked more to people from stanford
than i do
any other circle in my life social
circle
okay so we have time for maybe one more
question
and this does tie kind of closely into
this um
[Music]
daniel ortiz you might want to start but
others are welcome to join
um there's a couple questions about why
you
ultimately decided to return to brazil
versus staying
in the united states um if you could
shed any light onto that thought process
sure um i think for me there were two
main reasons i think the first one
i already alluded to but in my second
year i co-organized a steady trip to
brazil
and at the time as frankly not 100 sure
if i wanted to come back or stay abroad
and i think organizing this trip gave me
access to the types of speakers and
leaders and you know people were
influencing the direction of the country
in a way that gave me insight to say hey
actually i think this is a very
interesting moment
to go back to brazil there's a lot going
on that i think i could be
helping build and work on so
organizing the trip helped me understand
better what was happening in brazil in a
way that i wouldn't be able to
without without this opportunity and
that was very important
so i think that was one and then second
i think it has to do with impact i think
uh there's just so much to to build and
invest in and to help develop in brazil
and i think having a degree from
stanford and the connections and the
learnings that come with it
um i also felt a bit of a response a
sense of responsibility to
to come back and try and do my part in
helping the country
overcome its challenges so i think these
were the two
main reasons
yeah i would totally echo that i felt
the need to
i was born and raised in brazil and i
felt the need to come back here and help
my country to to develop the ecosystem
here so
it was really uh clear for me that i had
to go
to come back to brazil and also like on
the personal side uh
my partner and family are here so i
thought also
it would make more sense to be close to
to them so
thank you to all our panelists for
sharing your
experiences and you know just providing
so much insight into what it was like
and
the friendships that you built i knew
the alumni question would be very
uh close to home for the this brazilian
group i know you've been very very
strong
on my network i hope to see your
application in future years i hope to
see you throughout the summer at
other events and just i thank you so
much for taking time to join us today to
hear from our alums and to learn a
little bit more about stanford
thank you all take care stay healthy and
we'll see you soon
[Music]